[Musique]
merci Julie corona pour le temps avec
nous pour l'exposition là que vous êtes
si prépare en dalonnage l'entourage
pourquoi elle a dit oui
parce que voilà
c'est c'est le partage et de découvrir
d'autres artistes d'autres œuvres voilà
c'est une unité et puis renforcement
[Musique]
comment on peut décrire ou travail à eau
pour apprendre donc ma foi normalement
quand vous voulez autodidacte tu trouves
votre style par eux-mêmes en fait et
définirait comme un peu de
figuratif et de mélange de surréalisme
en même temps
et est-ce que l'on peut dire couler dans
une quête
identité
ça c'est un sujet qui revient beaucoup
surtout par rapport à mon nom cambona on
connaît que dans la réunion n'a que nous
appelles comme ça notre famille est pas
comme ça cambona et nous la fait des
recherches un moment donné et
un moment donné il bloque il trouve plus
de traces et une demande à maman m'a
toujours demandé où ça nous sort
[Musique]
ons
en fait
un peu en référence aussi un très grand
artiste que il respecte beaucoup c'est
williamsit il inspire moi beaucoup de
beaucoup inspire moins de son travail et
effectivement dans mon bandeau n'a que
bancafrine c'est parce que moi
d'ailleurs mon nom il pense que il sort
au tabac parce que nous connaît que
Mozambique un petit village appelle
comme donc cambona et
cette partie là bas de découvrir que ça
que ça il en a quoi c'est vrai qu'il
travaille sur Montpellier mais il y a un
thème qui revient souvent très cher à
moi aussi c'est la musique
[Musique]
la musique fait partie intégrante de ma
vie
s'il pourrait dire un peu plus que la
peinture même tu vois parce que il fait
pas passer une journée sans écouter de
la musique des journées sans peindre
parce que toujours en musique en fait et
là dessus là c'est
on a voulu
parle aussi de de l'équilibre et là nous
voit bien une femme en équilibre sur une
balançoire ou les fils en train de
s'effilocher là les laisser les oiseaux
après quand les fils vont casser c'est
les oiseaux qui vont la tenir en fait
l'équilibre entre l'homme et la nature
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer à nous
comment on travaille donc toujours en
musique et comment il se passe la
création d'un tableau
en fait imagine toujours le tableau
avant dans ma tête et puis à chaque fois
il compose un truc c'est toujours au
dessin commence toujours par le dessin
mais commence par exemple par exemple
sur un personnage principal et après au
fil du temps au fil de la composition
d'autres éléments qui qui apparaissent
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut dire à nous qu'on sort
la commence pas mais surtout pourquoi on
a commence pas parce que vous voulez
autodidacte
très jeune à l'âge de 8 ans
de des bandes dessinées des trucs comme
ça
l'idée de peindre est venu à moi un peu
plus tard vers l'âge de 18-19 ans comme
il voyait des expositions et
les venus à moi l'idée de mettre de la
couleur dans mes dans mes dessins en
fait c'est comme ça que les venus la
peinture est-ce qu'on peut dire à nous
de quoi
on rêve
de continuer de peindre enfin parce que
c'est ma passion avant tout et de
continuer à le faire jusqu'à très tard
quoi merci beaucoup j'ai mes corona
merci beaucoup